on a day that I was traveling to Las
Vegas for the conference that I've been
broadcasting from our friend Kyle
kolinsky over at secular talk had a
really great clip which piggybacked onto
the clip that Ben Dixon did analyzing
Donald Trump's interview with The
Associated Press and Kyle picked up Doug
in specifically to some statements that
Donald Trump made about how his Mexican
wall will stop all drugs from getting
into the United States let's take a
listen to Kyle's analysis of this I want
to go ahead here and give you guys a
portion of the interview on the border
wall to show you how childish his
thinking is and just show you how wrong
he is and really let let this marinate
in your brain think about how a colossal
absurd the idea is that he's getting at
so The Associated Press asks what do you
think the estimate on it would be
talking about the border wall here's
what Trump says oh I'm seeing numbers 24
billion I think I'll do it for for ten
billion or less that's not a lot of
money relative to what we're talking
about if we stop 1% of the drugs from
coming in and will stop all of it but if
we stop 1% of the drugs because we have
the wall they're coming around in in
certain areas but if you have a wall
they can't do it because it's a real
wall that's a tremendously good
investment 1% the drugs pouring through
the through on this other border are
unbelievable we're becoming a drug
culture there's so much and most of its
coming from the southern border the wall
will stop the drugs what the [ __ ] that's
the President of the United States Dawg
he really thinks a wall is going to stop
the drug trade he really thinks a wall
is going to stop the drug trade that's
the silly
thing I've ever heard could you imagine
you're in a Mexican drug cartel and you
you hear well they're building the wall
well we had a good run let me take my 13
billion dollars and go lay on a beach
somewhere no they're going to [ __ ]
find a way cuz I'm sure a lot of the
drugs come in through plane already or
throw through boat through other avenues
like what the [ __ ] what is happening in
your mind do you have like a parade of
900 Mexicans just carrying these giant
packages of coke on their back how
stupid are you Don when I was watching
Kyle talk about this and he spot-on by
the way my mind actually went to the
long-form piece we did on undocumented
immigration to the United States and in
that piece I debunked many of the
talking points that are commonly held
about undocumented immigrants this
includes for example undocumented
immigrants commit crime at a higher rate
than you know non undocumented
immigrants in the u.s. really a lot
they're a drain on the economy etc etc
but at the top of that list of sort of
false notions about even building a wall
not only is Trump wrong that the wall
will stop all drugs from getting into
the u.s. because as Kyle says there's
things called planes there's things
called boats etc etc the wall would not
even stop that many undocumented
immigrants from getting into the United
States aside from a drugs specifically
as Kyle talks about and it's actually
even more obvious because you can fly
into the u.s. you can take a boat into
the u.s. etc but you can also come in
regardless of how you're physically
coming in you can come in with a visa
that you overstay and so the the the
sort of naivete that Donald Trump
presents when it comes to this wall he
treats it almost like it's like a
childish thing I'm going to build the
wall to keep everything bad out it's
like what you would tell him I was going
to say a six year old but I think by the
time a kid is six you
would actually get into more nuance in
detail it's maybe the story you would
tell a three or four-year-old right
we're putting up the wall to keep the
bad guy out ignoring the sort of nuances
and details of that and at every level
and Kyle was right talking about the
drug aspect of it and our piece our long
form piece about this issue looked more
at the idea of even keeping undocumented
immigrants out is not something that a
wall would do so effectively it's just
fantasy world fantasy world and the
saddest part of it is that because Trump
believes that the believes in these sort
of caricatures of how his ideas would
work it makes him more likely to pursue
bad ideas and many times to pursue
solutions that wouldn't work as I've
said before two problems that don't even
exist you can check out the full segment
over on Kyle's channel secular talk by
clicking on the link in the video
description below